(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] There is a
place in northern Guizhou
where spice reigns supreme.
It's become known, simply,
as China Chili City.
(speaking in foreign language)
The town is home to the
largest chili market in China,
which produces countless
tons of chilies annually.
One worker can manually process
over 200 pounds of chili every day.
(speaking in foreign language)
The market processes
many types of chilies,
but each has a flavor
profile unique to Guizhou.
Instead of a numbing level of spiciness,
found in neighboring provinces,
the peppers from Guizhou are uniquely
both sour and spicy.
(speaking in foreign language)
The peppers are then
shipped around the world,
and the locals are fiercely proud
of their fiery export.
(speaking in foreign language)